hey you do whatever you want to do
you could even grab and re-grab this one
yes you're losing your balance
you want to do something else yeah
why do you found it
so
okay
project the arm with you
books
[Music]
feel the resistance
go with it
right there is your throat
watch
your toes right there
don't pull it
go inside the resistance
you're trying to pull it down
throw
always reach for content
content
write this
[Music]
good
connection
then you are going to come in right so
that's what it means
you change your grip
come around whatever you want
there you go
[Music]
see this instead of pushing here
again connection
connection
in the position
they're not just here
but
here
then you change what you want
let me do it
change what you want
good
connection
deviation help good
again do that one again strike into
headlock
good slip easy
so what i got
what i oh does that feel right go press
good move
connection
deviation she'll come again
into this
[Music]
connection projection
you can resist the projection
if you don't want to
connection projection so you can resist
the projection
you can counter it
good
[Music]
connection deviation
you're gonna push don't do it
always
follow the end space
all right
here we go
okay so when you're doing this playing
uh
you don't want to force it okay you
can't out muscle the person okay
but she goes to grab
and i don't want to
do this stuff do you see
can i can i project her yes
but i'll keep the connection and yield
to it okay and what i like to play with
is that she's using me
for balance you see and so then
you can find your thing
and as easy as moving through this space
here
that's what i'm trying to do
so yeah i'll get
her bowels and she'll want to muscle
that and that's where i can use
this stuff so she'll go again whatever
and i'm letting her move
letting her move
up
i want to switch
so feel that pressure take it off
turn your butt
[Music]
see how you're trying to push it out
wait
don't push
don't worry just touch here
stage there okay
uh
where does this hand want to go
where do you feel it
wants to go that way
wait
you're going the wrong way stop what's
up
this is not correct extension
so look
tell me what changes on this stop
tell me what changes from your arm here
and your arm here
nothing except you now have your bicep
here
go here you see it wants to go that way
turn that way
throw it on this one
see how you pushed on me can you see
that let it clear headbutt
boom you headbutt me
boom okay
[Music]
you want to push on it you see you're
trying to push on it move yourself out
from under
you got it let's do it again
here move out from under
good take the back
good okay
get out of the way feel the resistance
where does it want to go let it go that
way
don't pull it
go over the top
good that did it okay
and turn
turn your body
turn your lower body
and bow
do it again
boom
turn disarm is not don't fight it
turn your body
keep it with you
turn bow
you understand is non-contest station if
you go
you're here you'll get me
you see
here you go i can have your center
try to get up
go
i could do that
and watch how different this feels
go
you see that okay stay keep pushing
and i'm going to have your center
you're doing the pushing
okay
okay you're not interest you're in her
arms you're you're pushing where she's
pushing you you have to find her center
you have to first compromise her center
that's what's going to make her want to
adjust and do things
and then when we're playing coq hall
endings not in the game
right
can you always start over
inner center no this remote see how
she's standing straight up
do something maya there you go
and start over
inner center
these are all external
so when it's external then
you have to wait to the next beat before
you she
you you create the in space by moving
okay and then then she might go into it
she might but she can often counter it
not go into it
over here
and i don't want to go here
it's in your body
you see in your body
not not over here yeah yeah i pull i can
pull your arm and eventually your center
goes you see that so not not over here
not aiming that way it's touching you
here but it's in your body in your body
so if you want to come in
you see
okay if i aim over here you want to come
in yes you can come in
okay so whom in your body doesn't
doesn't matter where i'm at do you see
if then you have to make a serious
attempt to come in you see there you go
you make the seriousness come in and
then your yields work better okay
if i'm over here and you make an attempt
to come in oh crap
so i'm in the body
we can hold it
and i'm letting you go i let you go
so even here on your neck not here on
your neck in the body you see the
difference
boom in your body
in your body you'll have to do a serious
attempt
then my yields work better
but right from that you can do whatever
you don't have to keep reaching for me
in your body
in your body here with my shoulder
push on me
do you think hi in your body with my
shoulder
i will go whatever
in your body in your head you see it's
not in the arms go ahead push
push
and i can guide you too come back
oh you're trying to get heals but i can
as you push i could take it into things
write a touch
in your body in your body feel feel it
you can of course
with that skill right
you don't have to play the game
you can come in
right
you know right away but i would like to
to have you work on he changed on me
okay you could change do you see any
changes on me
that's what i wanted me with
you got it okay okay
but you should have that much center
control
right at contact with whatever's
touching okay